[Music]
how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome to friend
[Music]
when you put part one in the title we
expect a part
i still have our world that's something
there is still hope gamers patience
huh logan huh invent a new sport
spread it around the world be better
invent new sport no one else wants to
play it
your world chat
that is so good i love that what did uk
invent curling
cricket cricket mate football darts
rugby golf golf all right i guess i
could have guessed that
you're browsing the internet unprotected
oh
this video is sponsored by nordvpn
greatest vpn
best vpn so good but felix why use vpn
well
you can watch and download from anywhere
in the world you want to be in
america watch american shows you want to
british british show
japan no i don't think they have china
actually i mean
choose from over 5 000 servers in 59
different countries which i think is
important
the internet should be open no borders
get past
all that bs we all know what you like to
do online
yeah i know what you're doing online
stop it just kidding you can keep going
just download vpn
and all your internet data stays safe
behind
a wall of next generation encryption
next in generation
that sounds awesome if you never used
nordvpn before
they have a 30-day risk-free money-back
guarantee so try it out
30 days hey i like it it's not gonna
happen but if you don't
try it you got nothing to lose so take
control of your internet experience
today
but wait more yeah i haven't told you
about the bonus have i
bonus huge discount of a two-year plan
and you get additional bonus four months
three
four months for free that's like a lot
of
days risk-free with nordvpn's guarantee
you got nothing to lose check out the
link in the description nordvpn.com
pewdiepie enter code pewdiepie you're
welcome
bonus thank you november for sponsoring
this video
let's keep going did sweden did we
invent any sports
floor ball floor gang
floor ball floor ball
you want to play some player bull oh in
the bundy oh my god that's so fun
floor ball you call it floor ball you
impression it's in the bundy floor ball
yeah that's super fun i don't know why
that's not more popular it's
it's a great sport play that all the
time with gym clients
i always liked fleur ball cube oh [ __ ]
is that that's a sport i thought it was
just a game
it's like a long game you can play with
many people
it's like an advanced beer pong i don't
know what to call it
it's supposed to knock over each other's
clip
bunny as well no yeah why is this a
thing i never understood
it's like hockey but with a ball and it
hurts like a god
damn mother flipper to get hit by that
ball
sledge hockey all right all right what
the hell is swedish football
we basically took football from england
but there was confusion
we played it with an oval ball
[Music]
oh that's what americans did oh no we're
as dumb as
americans oh no i'm joking americans
all right it's bald road to space on a j
oh my god how did i not make that
connection
has an evil laugh oh my god it was right
there online
jeffrey jeffrey bases
hey you want to see the greatest picture
i have of jeffrey basis don't ask
why i say this it blows my mind that
this is exists but
it's jeffrey basis eating mark
zuckerberg
[Music]
what the [ __ ] faces what the [ __ ]
you're all mad about him not paying
taxes he ate it like one
that's messed up man an elegant solution
to that sniper wolf couch problem
oh wow there it is
someone show this to sniper wolf
she thought she had the wrong couch
that's so good that's so clean
this piece doesn't do it doesn't work go
in their couch
well done that's big peepee i like that
very clean addicts before and after
cocaine
so sad alcohol oh heartbreaking crack
cocaine
g fuel hell yeah hell yeah
i'll have some of that g fuel boy that
dude who discovered milk explaining what
he was
doing to the cow nice
yeah yeah i've thought about this it's
it's messed up as well mate what did you
do
imagine the first guy you're like guys
you gotta you gotta check this out got
it
that cow's nipples suck on them trust
trust me bro
trust me bro calcium bro your bones so
strong brook come on just do it but wait
wait wait
the cow has to be pregnant it has to be
terror milk yeah that's right
actually i don't know it's nothing weird
about it at all i don't
next pewdiepie thumbnail link oh cool
thanks i held up the sign a few good
screen caps
are already posted but here are my
favorites wait what
oh hell yeah smackdown
beautiful there that's ginormous pp
credit right there
hell yeah mr adam galaxy
galaxy penis status right there i'm
getting married oh
getting married today i want to thank
felix and the pro army for all the good
times bravo man bravo
you've been uh with me through the highs
and lows today i'm happy to take a step
further and it started
with the g field the best way to start
the day
love that happy for you man thanks for
sticking around
choose wisely i can't govern love scene
has this me not played its course come
on
come on don't soil the esteemed
reputation of the pewdiepie subreddit
please
please i mean it is a tough choice if
you think about it because
on the one hand cat girl on the other
hand
[Music]
randomly watching old videos and
realized pewdiepie used to live right
next to me and not
that was just my office and we got
kicked out from making too much noise
for the second time i gave up having
offices after that
what what am i looking at oh
oh sorry i've had a warning before this
how oh god oh god
when the eyes go up and down whoa what
was that
all right the full view of my face
which which oh it's kind of fun to pause
in this
oh that's a good one oh i love that
um icky is this of course
austin bradley bro that is so cute
i feel like we got to give austin some
recognition he's been popping these out
left and right
can you make ballet song that'd be cool
please thanks pewdiepie mocks
nikolo's hideous 2 million dollar home
what the [ __ ]
it why is this an article i don't want
to complain
they picked a great photo that's some
chat right there
yeah [ __ ] her i don't like her and her
stinky house
and you know what that original i don't
even remember this song
3d printed themed arcade machine took me
four years
that is not real is that 3d no
now austin bradley you got some
competition my dude
is that real is it real oh he worked
with austin that's awesome
i'm proud to unveil a project i've been
working on since 2017 a compact arcade
machine
a device that is full of getting
approved the more you play the bigger
the frame you get hey all right and ppm
i would assume
it's number just like the pewdiepie
figurines i hope i can ship
the number to felix
it's small size make it perfect for a
japanese bro
i mean it seems like i'm never going to
[ __ ] japan
i'll write you mane that looks so clean
it looks too clean to be real
no [ __ ] way that's sick
no it it folds up that's so cool
hell hell yeah damn
my brain my brain that is
so damn cool belongs in the museum
in a museum that's how much it belongs
in a museum
you need a micro museum in the museum to
put a museum and then you put there you
know what triple muse
how do you think the joystick stick is
going to fit yeah i guess you have to
unscrew it right
yeah the shaft unscrews it's actually
like it looks so clean all right my mind
is blown
giga penis hey people young fan here
thank you so much for
making this painful pandemic a little
great since i saw you thank you
for watching it was rough from the
philippines with hope my family managed
to have a new start
in canada and saw this hey that's nice
the pilgrimage continues i can't believe
that sign is still there
what happened to my camera and i can't
believe i was literally on that freaking
street strutting about
and someone forgot to tell me i am so
i'm literally just watching all these
other people to be a philosopher
one must ask a lot of questions
yeah yeah okay
you can only pick one
true baby can a pringle do this that's
right baby old meme we're bringing it
back
oh jesus huh
is it fresh and ripe to bring back can
you do this memes yet
felix parents in their 30s let's give
our children bright futures
felix in his 30s pringles aren't real
they just teleport i still haven't found
an answer
can someone show me how the pringles get
to the thing
then i might consider it everyone
talking flat earth i talk
how kurt pringle yeah yeah let's see
the first episode of minecraft
hell yeah
yeah [ __ ] it up beautiful 10 out of 10.
oh my god edgar gaming he doesn't have a
bow in anything so we should
have your gaming do it okay you can do
it
it all comes down to this
i was waiting for the edgar moves
honestly
he's so cute my
[Music]
he probably cheated or something huh
what do you think statistically emmy
why is my camera keep flipping up i
bought a new camera guys
big announcement but it's not arrived
yet so
yeah thank you yo
okay so i practice kendall now and she's
holding the sword upside down
a little cringe
guys literally only want one thing
you're coming gotta like from pewdiepie
hell yeah yeah i don't
i don't hand those out to just anyone
you are correct thanks for noticing
bruh isn't it weird to think we have the
same brain as caveman
i don't like that actually it's not
weird at all it makes perfect sense
looking at
stop a camera don't make that rock
yeah isn't it weird how we have the same
pringle does it backflip
beards oh yeah oh i forgot to mention
this
this is a fun fact for you pringle
pringle fans out there
uh the creator of pringles was buried in
the pringles cane
that's right it was one of his dying
wishes i told this to my sense she said
i want the same huge sand doesn't care
what people say there's crazy
live-action and funny gameplay videos
periods now
eyebrows internet on camera please don't
cancel me
[Music]
obligatory reddit whining bruh why do
you want me to want me to go out
and act like an idiot again it was funny
for its time
all right if i went out and did it again
you guys wouldn't even like it
let's get real homie i've been doing
this for what 12 years
let me chill all right i'm 31
remember that's like 90 in youtube
standards
uh you've scrolled for too long rest
here with us
we are a traveler that's so cute i like
that
[Music]
a rare photo of maya not hating me
because i'm rubbing her belly
pewdiepie twin blade
but bro you gotta show the whole thing
oh it's a twin blade
see i couldn't even tell
oh the power oh
bro you gotta show you show the process
but not the result
come on still get big pee pee back come
on
oh that's amazing
eggy lemonade i'm really proud of it
yeah it's amazing
it always makes me laugh hope he sees
this oh iggy
hey phil has been watching you since
amnesia in 2011
i think old school nine-year-old all
right three years ago i was saying i was
a life-threatening
appendix rupture and underwent major
surgery and only recently determined
muscle ball thanks for making me laugh
there's
recovery even though it hurt to laugh i
still felt good
nice speedy recovery blisses it's fun to
make it seem like he
like go to the doctor no i'm using this
home remedy called g-fuel
it heals all wounds and surgeries guys i
got felix and pewdiepie at the same time
on p
no no uh tuber simulator came out with a
new update
called meme maker so next time tag your
post for the y with me maker
and i'll review the best ones hashtag
meme maker one word
make your memes in tuber simulator
that's right baby
the game never dies thanks for all the
memes this week it always cheers me up
to do this i really appreciate it thanks
for watching
brofist you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use
any item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator
add some of our patented stickers in
there stickers our emotions
memes our emotions express your emotions
with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this